fire up your golden tommy gun and
rekindle your relationship with your
estranged son
you are not
who probably never existed because we
have capone the story of tom hardy
trying to win an oscar
there are a ton of unanswered questions
we'll be getting into like the
significance of the golden balloon who
that young boy was and if capone really
buried millions of dollars
so in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into capone's ending
much of its hidden symbolism and the
real life events and
characters portrayed in the film we
begin in what is most likely
thanksgiving 1945 about a year and two
months before his death in january of
1947.
capone had spent seven years in alcatraz
for a tax evasion and would later spend
the rest of his life in florida
never returning to his past life of
crime in chicago capone's wife mae even
has to tell others like gino not to
refer to capone as
al since that's what he was known as in
his past
gina
we don't say that name here capone plays
with the kids outdoors holding on to a
golden rod
gold is one of the recurring motifs
throughout the film the frame even holds
on a golden gramophone as he chases the
kids around the house
and the statue of julius caesar here is
adorned with gold
armor and sword capone is like caesar an
emperor-like figure who will see a
tragic end in his hallucinations he'll
end up killing his best friend geno who
he fears is a traitor
just like brutus betrayed caesar if you
listen closely you can hear puccini's
nesendorma play which translates to
nobody shall sleep it even features the
line but my secret is hidden within me
just like capone keeps the secret to his
buried money
locked within his mind gold is the
perfect motif for capone as it
symbolizes wealth
greed ambition self-centeredness and
arrogance
all things which capone encapsulates
during thanksgiving speeches he talks
about how his family started out with
nothing
but now they live in extravagance for
capone thanksgiving isn't about family
or
giving thanks for what they have it's
about showing off their wealth to those
who used to put them down
so every every year about this time we
get together
as a family and we shove it
in brooklyn's face rewinding back capone
has his first hallucination of a young
boy while in the rain
in the credits this boy is listed as
young tony
capone's illegitimate son but throughout
the film there is reason to believe he
takes on
aspects of capone himself let me first
start off by saying there is no
compelling evidence that capone had an
illegitimate son
let alone a son who was working with the
fbi and would later show up to see
his dying father the sun here is rather
a device used by writer director josh
trank to have capone reconcile with his
past
something that won't come easy for our
protagonist as the film progresses we
see capone slowly succumb to his illness
he sweats profusely vomits and
routinely can't control his bodily
functions capone used to work as a
bouncer and a brothel in chicago where
it's believed he contracted syphilis
this progressed into neurosyphilis which
infects the central nervous system
and can cause dementia we routinely see
capone forget who he is and at one point
he calls the police saying he's been
kidnapped later when dr carlock checks
up on capone capone refers to him as
j edgar hoover the former head of the
fbi who is responsible for bringing down
such notorious gangsters
like babyface nelson and machine gun
kelly along with capone's declining
health are also
his riches he's bleeding money and many
of his homes
statues and paintings have to be sold to
make ends meet
this is where the importance of his
supposed 10 million dollars of buried
cash comes into play
something we'll get into in a bit over
the radio capone is haunted by
reenactments of the saint valentine's
day massacre an event which saw the
murder of seven members of chicago's
north side gang
at the time prohibition was in full
swing and rival gangs fought for control
over territory
capone headed the italian south side
gang against the irish north headed by
george bugs marin
men believed to be associated with
capone at his orders dressed up as
police officers and brutally murdered
some of the north side's top gang
leaders
in one fell swoop however capone was
never charged and the perpetrators never
identified the radio also refers to
capone as scarface a nickname given to
him by the media of which he apparently
loathed early in his career capone
inadvertently insulted a woman at the
nightclub he was working at which
resulted in the woman's brother slashing
him in the face
giving him those scars as the film
progresses capone starts seeing
paintings of a young boy on a farm a boy
wearing the same outfit as young tony
looking at a farmhouse with a beam of
light from the heavens descending upon
it
these paintings become a recurring motif
throughout the film
we see one here of the same boy working
the fields and later on of several
balloons floating skyward during his
near-death experience at the end of the
film where capone suffers from a stroke
he visits this farmhouse where the boy
looks over him the golden balloon
floats away just like capone's life
slowly slips away from him
balloons also symbolize freedom and
release and since it's a golden balloon
it can be his freedom from greed
wealth and earthly possessions it's
quite fitting since the next scene we
see him sitting in his empty house where
all his things have been sold
it's unclear why tranq chose an italian
countryside as this heavenly metaphor
for capone
perhaps because capone's parents grew up
there capone himself grew up in brooklyn
so it's a bit odd dr carlock who we
later find out is working with the feds
to get info about the missing money
looks after capone's deteriorating
health according to real-life reports a
year before capone's death capone had
the mental capacity of a 12-year-old
we're then introduced to capone's friend
johnny he's invited down by may
likely in an attempt to cheer capone up
and have him be around familiar faces
just like the doctor ordered the strange
thing about johnny is that we the viewer
aren't sure if what we're seeing is real
or not in this way we're made to feel
just like capone although mae is the one
to invite him down we never see him
interact with her we see capone having a
drink with johnny but when may asks him
who he's talking to
no one is there perhaps only the first
two scenes with him
actually happened or perhaps none at all
johnny becomes this specter of capone's
past
life he tells capone how grateful he is
for taking him off the street and it's
revealed he was the one
tortured and stabbed by geno for
skimming cash off the top
and allegedly working with the feds like
many of the characters in this film
johnny isn't based off a real life
person the only significant
johnny in al capone's life was johnny
torrio who was his mentor but he died of
a heart attack and was significantly
older than al
in one of the more gruesome scenes of
the film johnny scoops out his eyes
telling capone the key to the money can
be found in these
the eyeballs are placed directly looking
at him the key is inside of him
in his mind the tragedy is that he can't
reach it capone watches the wizard of oz
and sings the cowardly lions if
i were king of the forest he literally
has the lion's face projected onto him a
shell of the lion he once was
in the wizard of oz the cowardly lion is
looking for courage and courage is a big
theme in capone
capone tells johnny maybe if yeah had
some coverage
you might be able to find yourself some
new friends
and earlier when geno kills johnny he
says where's your [ __ ] courage now
capone himself does not have the courage
to confront his past specifically his
son
it isn't until the end of the film that
he rekindles that relationship
unlike johnny may actually speaks to
tony here leading me to believe this end
scene isn't a hallucination
and capone is fraught with
hallucinations most notably the party in
the 1920s featuring louis armstrong
there are no accounts of louis or al
ever meeting but since many of the clubs
louis played in at the time
were run by the mob it isn't a stretch
to believe they might have met
in fact there's a famous quote from
louis in which he says capone demanded
louie's name be taken off the marquee
and louis defiantly said no then there's
the question of
this woman in a gold dress no less she's
credited as
mona lisa and set up as capone's
mistress however there's no evidence to
suggest he had one
capone and his wife mei married when he
was 19 and by most accounts their
marriage was happy
we see these two photos in his office at
the club which are the same photos
johnny brought up to show him in florida
further proof of his hallucinations
meshing into one another
capone asked this woman an odd question
where is the kid meaning this woman is
likely the mother of tony his
illegitimate son
i also want to briefly show this young
version of tom hardy as al capone
because i think that could have been a
way cooler film the club has shot up but
there's no record of capone ever being
involved in a club shooting of this
scale let alone one with louis armstrong
inside so this is more of a metaphor for
the violence he and the mob
unleashed on the city we see him soaked
in blood literally climbing over
bodies of the dead bodies he had to pile
up to get where he was
in the distance is the boy with a gold
balloon he yells mama
is hurt further proof that this woman is
tony's mother
ralphie capone's older brother asks al
if he hid any money
as kids capone never trusted anyone and
never wrote anything on paper instead he
hid it all in his mind
he always had it all up here
unfortunately for his struggling family
his
mind has gone rotten when interviewed by
the fbi he can't even remember his own
name
he later hallucinates shooting geno and
members of his staff with a golden tommy
gun while in reality he shot his
gardener in the leg
another event of which there is no
record by the swamp capone sees a safe
and is reminded of the clue mona lisa
gave him
dig where it is wet but this isn't
referring to the swamp at
all dig wear it as wet is referring to
his brain the thing capone had buried
away all this time
wasn't money at all it was the key to
something much more important
his son who he had cast away capone's
last living blood relative
believes that capone's hidden money is
real and that before his stay on
alcatraz he hid millions of dollars
across
several of his properties but as the
film notes no money was ever recovered
overall capone stretches reality to the
point of unbelievability
but that's kind of the point as we
witness these events through the lens of
a man
suffering from hallucinations and
dementia it's up to us to decipher the
real
from the imaginary thanks everyone for
watching please make sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes check
out my other videos and follow me on
twitter at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much